hidden in the new Knives Out mystery is
a ton of secret symbolism and Sly
details that predict the many twists and
turns yippie kai movie lovers I'm Jan
and in this video I'm peeling back every
layer of gloss onion to reveal all the
clues you might have missed spoilers
ahead of course so take care by the end
of the movie miles has been exposed as
Andy and Duke's killer so Helen Andy's
twin sister takes Revenge by Smashing up
his art setting the place on fire and
destroying one of the world's most
famous paintings the Mona Lisa however
in a clever bit of foreshadowing the
details of this big moment were laid out
much earlier when miles explained the
type of person he considered a disrupter
if you want to shake things up you start
with something small you break a norm or
an idea notice how Helen was paying
attention to Miles during his little
speech and she basically followed his
script starting with smaller pieces of
glass which stairs up whiskey and some
of the others everybody gets excited
because you're busting up something that
everyone wanted broken in the first
place then she moves onto bigger pieces
like his Liberace piano that Miles
actually begins to care about we break
more things break bigger things and then
she turns to the Mona Lisa the thing
that everyone in the room begs her not
to ruin be willing to break the thing
that nobody wants you to break and miles
of course tries to stop her they're
gonna tell you to stop nobody wants you
to break the system itself but that is
what true disruption is Helen also mocks
his gesture about crossing the line
employing it just before she actually
crosses the line truly disrupting his
world and sending his Empire based on
fakery and lies Up in Smoke we all got
to that line and crossed it disrupters
by the way the finale was also
foreshadowed when Helen received the
puzzle box intended for a sister Andy
and rather than playing along with
miles's game she smashed it open
destroying it but at the same time
solving the box is mystery and I think
there's a nice parallel here between
hell Marta from the first movie who also
refused to play the game by the rules
you won not about playing the game
Harlan's way for yours another clever
clue comes via the murder mystery game
that Miles organized for the weekend the
way miles is shot with a dart that
bursts open a pouch of fake blood under
his shirt telegraphs how when he shoots
Helen later she'll use Jeremy ranner's
hot sauce to pretend to be dead another
clue that Helen hadn't really died was
that Blanc wouldn't let anyone go near
her supposedly dead body shouldn't we
not going anywhere and the way miles
hides the diamond he stole from birdie
in plain sight in the necklace he puts
on for the evening replicates how he
also hid Andy's Red Envelope in plain
sight behind the fake napkin in his
office it also transpires that Miles
didn't even come up with the mystery
himself like he originally claimed but
instead hired author Gillian Flynn to
write it in a similar way to how he took
credit for Andy's original business idea
and the shout out to Flynn who's most
famous for her book and screenplay of
Gone Girl could be another nod to the
fact that later Helen is actually only
pretending to be dead one of the biggest
clues that there was something
suspicious about miles was the look of
absolute shock on his face when he saw
Andy turn up on his private island as
after all he knew he'd poisoned her just
days earlier Andy you're here I imagine
miles didn't know that Andy had a twin
so he must have thought she'd survived
the poisoning especially as news hadn't
broken yet about her death and I think
the way he weirdly touches her shoulder
after she arrives could be that he was
checking to see if she was actually real
and not just a figment of his
imagination or a ghost I really am glad
you're here interestingly Claire was
perhaps the only one who sensed early on
there was something odd about fake and
deeds nothing's off she's changed
there's some delicious secret symbolism
in the names of twin sisters Andy and
Helen Andy is short for Cassandra who in
Greek mythology had the gift of Prophecy
but was cursed to never be believed and
she also had a twin sibling called
helenus and we see all this play out in
the movie as Andy warned miles that his
clear hydrogen technology was dangerous
and would end up causing a disaster
which comes true in the finale
Hindenburg
also like her Greek counterpart nobody
believed Andy in court when she sued
miles stating that she was the one who
came up with the original idea for Alpha
additionally in the Greek myths
Cassandra predicted that the arrival of
Helen of Sparta in Troy would lead to
the destruction of the city similar to
how the arrival of Helen on miles's
private island eventually leads to his
downfall like the Trojan Horse which
Greek myths Cassandra warned about Helen
and Blanc infiltrate miles as Abode and
destroy it from within and a clever
little detail pointing to Andy's secret
twin is the mug we see her drinking from
at home which is a two-faced head of the
Roman God Janus as its design and given
that this particular God is associated
with Beginnings the Mug's design is
doubly appropriate for Andy as she was
the true originator of alpha blank's
undercover role was also foreshadowed
when he first appears and is in the
middle of the game Among Us playing the
role of an imposter in a manga one of
the major objectives for imposters is to
sabotage the mission and in Glass Onion
Helen another imposter triumphs by
destroying miles's treasures and Legacy
and fellow impostor Blanc helps her get
the means to do it by the way Blanc
accidentally gave away that fake Andy
wasn't who she appeared to be when he
called her Helen momentarily in the
aftermath of Duke's death Helen did you
take Duke's gone and that's before we
knew who she really was
the Amiga symbol is a recurring Motif in
the movie appearing on miles's super
yacht deck chairs on the boat dressing
gowns and the Amiga brand watch and
miles's business Empire runs under the
banner Alpha the alpha and Amiga is one
of the names used for Christ or God in
the Book of Revelation and points to how
miles sees himself as a god-like figure
the two symbols are also the first and
last letters in the Greek alphabet which
relates to how the movie Chronicles the
beginning of miles's business Empire
when it was first conceived with the
idea he stole from Andy to the end of
his Reign when Helen torches his world
to the ground you can also see an
allusion to the beginning and end in
Andy's room via a painting of an
oroborus a snake eating its own tail
it's here where Andy discovers the
original napkin with the business plan a
moment which references both the
beginning and then with the Red Envelope
the end both for miles and for Andy as
he kills her over it when Helen rules of
her suspect chart for who might have
killed her sister she writes miles name
right next to the column headers for
motive and opportunity rather than on a
separate line like she does for everyone
else a subtle clue that miles is the
real killer and that they've overlooked
that fact when Helen points out that the
grid looks a little like a game card
from clue and comments that Blanc must
be good at the game he replies I am very
bad at dumb things come on kill his heel
kicking boxes running around searching
all the rooms it's just a terrible
terrible game Blanc doesn't realize yet
but it ends up that to solve the Glass
Onion mystery Helen in fact has to do
all those things kickboxes and run
around searching the rooms on the island
until she finds the hidden Red Envelope
as Blanc points out dumb simple
Mysteries are his Achilles heel and so
he dismisses the most obvious suspect
when Helen suggests it miles Brown is
not an idiot to risk commit murder after
a very public court case with a possible
quality of that email event is coming to
light would be an exceedingly stupid
thing to do and another hint that the
answer to the mystery will be a simple
one comes when Blanc comments to my
tomorrow I like the Glass Onion as a
metaphor an object that seems densely
layered but in reality the center is in
plain sight there's another clue to
where the evidence for Andy's murder is
hiding right at the beginning of the
movie when Duke receives the puzzle box
and his mother tells him that first
one's a Fibonacci sequence of course the
Fibonacci spiral in the box is very
similar to the one at the center of
miles's office behind which the Red
Envelope is hidden now this one might be
a little stretch but I think that as
well as being necessary to the puzzle
itself the missing Square in the end of
the puzzle box with its red background
is also a hint to the see-through glass
or hole in the Fibonacci spiral and the
red envelope behind that interestingly
the giant chandelier above miles's
dining table with little red squares in
among the white lights could be a nod to
the red envelope and his clear hydrogen
Rock another of the puzzles has a cheeky
hint to miles is idiocy the chess layout
and Checkmate move that Claire makes to
unlock the next level is called the
Fool's mate and is the quickest and most
foolish way a player can lose in chess
it requires that the player going first
make the worst possible opening two
moves a clue to how miles gives himself
a way to blonk in the most obvious
manner it hard not behind complexity but
behind manned Norman obvious Clarity it
doesn't hurt at all and I was staring
right at it after Duke discovers the
truth about Andy's death and makes the
deal with miles to get himself on Alpha
news notice how he deliberately hides
his phone from birdie when she wants to
see what's going on and there was a
little clue that there was something
happening in the rest of the world when
Claire's husband called her a few
moments earlier presumably to tell her
about Andy but she decided to ignore his
call there's a little hint to miles's
ponchon for killing his enemies via
spiked beverages when he says to Blanc I
apologize I don't know your drink but
you know pick your poison after Duke
dies his phone keeps pinging so Blanc
goes to look for it where's Duke's phone
it just dinged it must be here miles
backs off nervously at this point not
because he's scared of being murdered as
he claims but because he's already
stolen the phone to stop anyone
discovering the breaking news about
Andy's death and if you stop and look
really closely here you can spot a foam
poking out of his back pocket this has
to be Dukes as we already know that the
billionaire doesn't use a phone himself
and instead has fax machines send in
messages if unlike birdie you are
allowed on your phone then thanks to
this video sponsor nordvpn you can avoid
getting into trouble whenever you're
online nord's new threat protection
feature blocks spyware trackers and
malware so if you accidentally click on
a dodgy link Nord will block and delete
any malicious downloads immediately
keeping you safe and secure on top of
that Nord encrypts your internet
connection and conceals your IP address
so you can key keep all your online
activity private it stops your internet
service provider from knowing what
websites you visit and nord's threat
protection will also block those
third-party cookies that follow you
around the web bombarding you with
incredibly intrusive ads with Nord you
can connect up to six devices at any one
time so you can protect all your phones
laptops and computers and for a limited
time all our viewers can grab an
exclusive offer on a two-year plan with
a huge discount plus four bonus months
completely free just visit nordvpn.com
flicks or go to the link in the video
description to get the offer or use
coupon code flicks when you check out my
next video will be all the Easter eggs
you missed in Glass Onion which I'll
link to here as soon as it's ready so
how do you think the sequel compares to
the first knives out and did you spot
any other interesting details or Clues
let me know in the comments below tap
here for my next Knives Out video and if
you enjoyed this one do leave a thumbs
up I really appreciate it it thanks for
enjoying Glass Onion with me and hope
you have a marvelous movie loving week
yippee Kai movie lovers